I leave in are you on your way back home
either way we wanna be there doesn't
matter how much baggage you claim give
us time and a terminal and get
we wanna send you off inside we wanna
welcome you back home tell us all about
it we scared her was it fine now horn
do you need a ride do you need a mine do
you need a ride do you need a ride do
you need
with Kern and Chris welcome to do you
need a ride this is Chris Fairbanks
Karin kill Gareth as a stomach bug I
don't want to alarm anyone I think it's
not an actual bug that's horrifying if
you think about it though just an insect
inside her and I hate to put that in
your head because it's not what it is
she probably was just a stomachache
she's not here I am here with Todd Barry
hey hey Todd what's up getting our trip
back from the airport
yeah I'm really I'm used to you not
driving away that's because I'm terrible
podcasting while I'm driving it might be
time to make a choice - thank you dr i i
will put driving ahead of thinking of
witty things to say okay cuz that takes
all of my energy is trying to conjure
things that are interesting to say do
you want me to give you the directions
like on the air i think that two miles
you have I guess where I'll take a left
yeah yeah I know some of us stuff going
in here
but yeah and then that I have to shift
to asking you a question like how how
was New Orleans I know in fact you were
at the I was good I did
and for you the crowd work shows you
just do not allow yourself to do any
material now when you allow the audience
to be part because you are by cohn
having it be a crowd work show do they
act like no they don't
they're very tame like they're not oh
wow
I think it's because I get my fans who
are generally polite right awful and
smart right yeah so they're kind of into
it without being like all we get their
note they don't interpret it as oh we
get to yell scream or just beat yours
right I can only imagine it happening
that way people that are nice people
that think they're funny that are going
to your show instead of their first open
mic no it drives me nuts
what do you mean like going there to be
funny oh yeah yeah I mean it definitely
has happened
yeah how about the show we did in
Missoula wasn't that the most that was
fun right
I was really proud of my town yeah well
they were if you remember they were
polite and they listened they even
selected which jokes they thought were
good and bad we they really liked the
vid jokes ever reputation I guess the
other show we did there was kind of
rowdy like more drunken yeah people
drank a lot there and that crowd was
like nope let's sit and watch this why
do they drink so much little bit bored I
think it is boredom and I think it's
because it's cheap to buy alcohol and
it's expensive to buy food at
restaurants so people are like well I'll
just eat whiskey for dinner I'm serious
it's expensive teeth and maybe to get
food to Montana and then liquor is so
cheap
also yeah it's just a town that drinks a
lot I don't know like what's godson or
something I think they start drinking in
the wintertime out of bored of Alaska
they drink a lot and so even when the
weather is nice they're like well I'm in
the habit of drinking I might as well
record but they were it they just were
acting like an audience that magic
watches stand up a lot which did two saw
together Tucson was great at Tempe Tempe
I say Tempe and people will correct you
and say Tempe oh is it add a bunch of
ease at the end there unless someone
really is like disrespect right I I
think it's disrespectful when a town
like in Austin they have a street called
Guadalupe and I took enough Spanish in
college to know it's Guadalupe yeah
but they will correct you I'm like oh
I'm on Guadalupe they go don't you mean
Guadalupe and I'm which is just that
extra like remember the Alamo you know
like correcting a Spanish word that's
not
they even on the bus in Spanish when
repeating the directions they say you
know the next street is one loop and
then they look how they esta blah de
loop they mispronounce it in Spanish
maybe there's a reason maybe there's
like a history to it like you know we
have Houston Street in New York yeah
what you spelled like Houston okay so
maybe there's like a someone it was like
no I I know it's not the same yeah I
even my call I say Guadalupe it's my
guess is it's Texas calling it how
Houston when the word is House and Texas
likes to adopt words and it could be
just
yeah no probably not
Samuel H Houston H actually sounds like
it should be it should be oh I'm sorry I
was just paying attention to driving
straight on a road without any traffic
on it sometimes that takes all my brains
out oh yeah there those places
everything but the produce and I'll buy
they're limes but they actually produce
yeah they're grocery stores it's amazing
what you can get for now and it's a
really fun game to just fold stuff up
and say how much is this because it's
gonna be a dollar is Babbitt driving oh
right
I mean maybe like even the then
name-brand dishsoap
right yeah you think like what what's
like they're gonna make this big of a
profit but I remember one time at a
99-cent store I found $0.99 Tapatio
sauce which retails for like four or
five dollars and Ike I bought a bunch of
them like I'm just this hot guy hot
sauce yeah
so much Tapatio yeah there's times I've
ordered hot sauce and II realize oh I'm
not quite
is it the hot sauces I thought yeah as I
look at this bottle what I bought nine
years ago yeah I think it always makes
me feel bad when my dad will buy like a
giant you know you can get a Costco a
tub of mustard yeah and then you think
wow this might be the last mustard I
ever buy I might die before I finish
this I don't ever want that much of any
sauce they well that's how Costco works
they just they market themselves stories
you've done your choices
saw special oh really
so are they evil in some way no no it's
just it's smart like they have like
4,000 items in the store whereas like
Target might have for 35,000 right I
don't know if they're the exact numbers
but that's the idea so that's kind of
like hey there's eight sizes of Tylenol
that you can buy let's put them all over
that well put them all on the shelf so
you get frazzled when you're deciding
shares that here here's the 300 you want
that okay I guess yeah there's some kind
of futuristically lazy about that but
it's that I like going in and go you
know what I do need muffins and winter
tires and and jeans and tylenols that
membership thing
oh that's where they get you
like I went with my brother it's in a
place where there's a Costco
it's gonna be you know you mean like we
buy me these razor blades and I'll pay
you back and then it just feels weird
did you who don't belong to some Dollar
Shave Club or something I did join the
Dollar Shave Club answer my members oh
really
well they were I think I know if they
were great the best racers man I think I
bought the tool bottom tier version of
Dalek ship ah but also they were coming
at me so like like I don't shave for
time today
right right right go down and I think I
actually got a slower that can wake you
if you click to cancel their like is
this cuz we said them too much there's
like a secret little like there's the
secret Netflix like light program oh
that's interesting I do this Harry's
thing and it's just you order and when
you need I had yeah someone I know
someone who did marketing for them and
they hooked me up with Harry's one ranks
it's nice there's a Harry's story I
would go there
once you get a free one you know
yeah so you get upset to you I haven't
yet I just I haven't made it through the
first round of razors
it feels good though it's better than
the Gillette vibrating Mach 3 racecar
razor I had why do you see you pop you
bought one eye my dad got it for me it's
like I bought one of these and I got you
on I'm like a it's hard to get excited
about a simple razor when mine vibrates
I got through the vibrating Mario yes
you can't get word I have two of them my
dad always buys me razors I still really
that's cool you don't see good shaving
cream is uh
proraso you ever have that I thought
you're gonna say Barbasol that actually
is I got all these fancy ones and I was
like this is just yeah
no no that's something about being in a
car makes everyone say yeah me too I'm
pissed [ __ ] off right I got podcast
I'm the guy that doesn't notice where I
say pissed [ __ ] off no one's ever
said that Barbasol has alcohol in it it
dries your face makes you look wrinkly
is that what the guy makes my face hair
dollar no it's a good I think so
he was outdoors yelling at a parking
meter I'm thinking Barrasso get that
it's Italian you can get it for like ten
dollars to maybe cheaper it sounds it
sounds like a really good gonna put
spaghetti sauce on my face smells good
po rasa Pro rasa if today was your
birthday
goodbye you oh thanks if today was your
birthday and I said this that's a very
very well your temporary where you stand
just a friend
yes house I've never seen someone guest
house oh I've always wanted to live in
Modesto so what I mean
weird you don't want to say who the
friend is now like a famous Camille I
could tell you it's a is that he's got a
famous person's well his name's jonathan
groff but it's not the actor okay
copywriter oh wow
no no Conan's head right oh okay I knew
him when he was doing stand-up I would
know what he looks like then you need
that red haired guy well he hasn't been
there in the wind yeah I'm thinking of
blackish okay
beside me that you know I was weird that
bizarre
yeah all of a sudden yeah
I am you mentioned your brother I met
your brother it's so interesting to meet
siblings it blows my mind every time I
just met my roommates dad and it's just
a different version of him but it's the
same you can tell that it's your brother
but he had liked it different he was
like hey terrific like he's Persian
yeah I wouldn't say you said that before
and that's not what I'm saying folk so
I'm big fo selfi right right oh you're
taking around oh it's gonna be the same
to reroute yeah and it'll it'll he's not
better this industry yeah and you get to
see the Texas of Los Angeles all these
oil rigs just drilling for Bob I met
your dad right the first time
yeah yeah I wish you had been able to he
was golfing the whole time that we were
in Missoula he's like non-stop golfing I
think her her last minute he wants to be
people who loved golf really love golf
it sounds like that's all they
well it's funny because I've seen in his
life he'll get mad at golf and not do it
for a decade really yeah he's quit
forever before and then picks it off
well have you ever done it I've never
really golf like I lived in Florida
where all this golf course is right
across the street from me and I just
never I think I played like pitching
we're yeah no it isn't I mean because
it's something that it's hard to be good
at right away so it's frustrating it's
like a commitment if you want a golf you
better mark off a couple days a week for
the rest of your life so one day you can
maybe be good at it
it's very trusted I was okay it's swung
at it like it was a baseball doesn't
look fun though I mean I could see
probably why
yeah it's your outside that's I am
always calling you're hanging with your
friends yeah
assaulting each other do people drink a
lot of other golfer I used to in Austin
it helped me you were better golfer well
after two or three drinks because it
lubes you up no it did it helped it like
you think any the pros get drunk
probably not they know how to be loose
already
I would all be all stiff you know how
drunk people don't die when they're in a
car wreck that's how it helped me golf
and you have all these alcoholic
rationalisation yeah yeah that makes you
play golf better it does a day you won't
die in a car accident even though you
probably caused that accident no well
I've always thought driving in golf were
really similar that's right right now
I'm I'm three sheets come on I have a
golf with these uh I worked in a screen
printing shop and these guys were in an
Iron Maiden cover band
they have long hair and they were metal
heads yeah and they were the best
golfers I'd ever golf with really and
they got really drunk and part everyday
Hall it was bizarre
you're kind of taking a different route
here that's fine yeah yeah I think that
four miles want to go on right onto the
edge okay I've done this way before and
so I just started doing you know how
when you're like a lot of ways to skin a
cat yes yes and and when you're from an
area you don't you never you never pay
attention to how you're skinning a cat
you just know you're you're killing a
lot of cats in your hometown i I've 100%
I'm all for it I'm a cat man just
thinking a big deal
have your purse it's nice to your right
you should I think you should get it I
should get a kitten right um enjoy that
kitten experience I mean you can get a
pretty young cat I think at the places
you don't want him to have any baggage
no that's not that I just want the
experience I just thought how cute it
would be if we did adopt a cat it came
with baggage he has his luggage
yeah leftover sandwich he a the good
thing about cats that I think would be
frustrating with dogs as even leave them
right for several days with food and a
litter box and they're fine they not
true the several days things yeah
they're fine without humans they don't
need us that's why you don't see
homeless people with cats you don't know
with a cat following them around tonight
my man you have yes those are eccentric
people they're not
some homeless people are except if
you're legitimately homeless a lot of
work I guess in the city there's just
cats and people you know living in
tragedy yeah that's just an eccentric
guy he might be poor like a homeless
person there's a dude in New York who oh
wow
that's bizarre Davila cat I love cats I
had one but and I flew it to my dad's
because I moved into a place where I
couldn't have a litter box my place is
that small my places see that's the
problem mind like I've been looking at
fancy litter boxes I found one that's
like a top it's a top loader uh-huh I
don't think it would work well who's in
the kitten face but it's a it's the most
compact one and it's sleek looking but
it's still like it's just a little too
much hurt because I have a studio
apartment
it's a pretty big studio you're saving
your money then if you know what I was
spending you would not say oh that's
well there's things you can do I think
we can talk about it even off off get
off cast no I think I could just get
this litter box and deal with this right
my bathroom and you can get
self-cleaning ones that's the only gross
part is dealing I just want the smallest
possible because it's a small bathroom
right know what I did my next one dad
I had mine in my closet for a while it
was awful
that was the only space I had and and I
don't think I have to let you in on a
little secret I smells like cat piss all
the time captain I made friends with a
lot of old ladies during that time
though does this rodeo here is this the
different road I am this is the one that
I was supposed to turn right on should I
turn right on it well it doesn't say
that right
see I knew I knew Rodale was bad or
rodeo I'm hungry man
should we eat we can eat in Los Feliz I
know exactly where to go
really yeah right by where you're
staying
I don't know the name of it it's a lot
like streets in LA I just know where
it's located and that has a specific
restaurant yeah I was at the mustard
cafe it might be water together
why do you know the name of it no yeah
no I've been into the mustard seed cafe
I don't care from that place it's not on
that street you're mentioning places on
Vermont on Hillhurst yes Hill there's
just got a pretty good size yeah I know
like this yes but I hope they start
talking about cats again make your
dinner plans
no I'm I do want to talk about cats I'm
a bit I'm a cat man I like dogs - so
have you ever had a kid that's got its
nuts like I am a lot of crazy people out
here um yes I've had all ages that can
it phase that kid phase are they peeing
all over the place cats quickly learn
and instinctively learn how to use the
litter box
they do not it's not like a puppy who a
dog may piss everywhere else does I feel
like once a cat pisses you're done get
that smell out the cat pee is worse than
doctor yeah you you don't want him to
pee on anything that can't be washed
like a mattress that's it you think like
I've asked like I got when I like pet
finders not gums like something woman
and one of the joys like you want a male
or female yeah that's right well that's
because you're a feminist but I mean
seriously look if you get a cat it's not
like you're got an orientation towards
you know I've I've and it's gonna sound
terrible
my favorite cats have been male one
really and maybe it's a bonding thing
but I there's a neutered of course so
that that should bring them back to just
being yeah you know of
sexless Kitty because you're literally
cutting off their there so it's terrible
but you should do that if you do get a
cat or got to get it neutered yeah yeah
he's might go in the hallway and make
babies what's your name yeah that's the
worst
you gotta listen to Bob Barker so you
get that because I went to this pet
store the other day I slipped it like
little mini kit litter box and social
are adorable just imagine a little
kitten that scampering around in there
yeah just set down this luggage well
yeah I mean you might as well get the
big they are gonna be intimidated by a
full-sized litter box I don't think I
was told that you got to get a smaller
one
oh really well it's like I think prob
I mean I took it is like it's hard for
them to climb into him
well maybe it's a top loader you can't
get a top water you know that you might
I mean it's setting your sights a little
higher because not every cat is gifted
enough to do it my cat used to go in the
toilet seriously oh you could about that
but I've never known anyone so it's a
litter box especially if you get a young
cat you will pull it off it's it's a
litter box that is a circle of course
and in the middle there's sand also then
eventually take the middle compartment
out and then it's a sand doughnut so
they're kind of peeing around the edge
and after a couple weeks it's just a cat
carefully paying in your toilet
seriously yeah I've seen them do it it's
amazing you know is that on YouTube yes
cuz that's like the perfect solution
oh there's enough of them yeah you just
it would be you'd have to treat it like
your hobby for a while too you know and
it's kind of hard to train cats yeah
it's the best I think you'll like cattle
man they're there and they're
affectionate but not in your face all
the time like dogs often are like
every second they have to remind you how
much they love you it's like oh god
thought about that you're so desperate
like dogs are nicer you know the dogs
also will bite you and I'm like in a
million they'll kill a baby it'll be no
one no one should have brought that up a
bluebird ottoman brought it up
simultaneously unpredictable a cat will
scratch your baby sure I got scratched
as a baby by a cat Frank yeah I once got
scratched that just makes you a better
person you see the Steve Jobs know they
have another billboard of it
oh well weird cuz I'm seeing a Supergirl
billboard you know I'm seeing that looks
like Tori Amos that's pretty unlikely
for you Minoru and that she got 20 years
younger
be nice what's what areas is rightly
famous from the album under the pink we
are on La Brea right now so is this what
would you call this area Holly this is
just simply Los Angeles really there's
an area that's just simply was it well I
people dissect it make
I'm sure it's called like you know
County Park or something yeah I made
that outbound oh it's Gulf County Park
I'd see there's a sign that says County
museums I think this is called County
Museum Park this area this is called
Steve Jobs Steve Jobs Supergirl Park oh
man I just ruined the episode from the
back yeah you know that was a stinker
what I don't understand speaking of
billboards the walk I mean there's a
documentary we saw it actually happen
already in the documentary yeah you
don't need this see a dramatization no
no I think I heard that Louie's all
right though
you know what I'm a big fan of out
what's-his-name Gordon habit yeah he
doesn't have to have French Stewart with
him for me to like him a lot of people
need that French Stewart in the room did
you you saw man on wire yeah I mean I
was great
oh I get the documentary it's terrific
yeah the most amazing thing is that
there was no video yeah yeah they don't
actually cuz he was doing it if you
remind me he was doing it really of
course illegally and they didn't but did
the cops they arrested him I think he
got arrested yeah
it's probably what it was I mean that I
can't speak for the cops there's gotta
be like half like we gotta arrest this
guy and all the [ __ ] that's pretty funny
sometimes I like to speak for the cop so
I get a party today like all right
everyone time to go home it's not even
my party I should have called the cops
they wouldn't do anything
they wouldn't they did just write a
report say they were gonna look into it
those earphones are gone Oh drug dealers
they deal with drugs then who deal drugs
and ladies is that true murderers the
occasional retired murderer will stay at
the Royal Hawaiian it's shady people
that I see coming in and out of there
although I kind of like the Royal
Hawaiian motel it's got a history -
really yeah it's got a little chic look
there's a little mask tiki mask
I miss this Edgewood we are in that's
great because it's a taco truck but then
they have a little building where you
can go eat them
oh really yeah it's great isn't that
because I guess the part of the trucking
the truck thing I don't like yeah yeah
you have to stand by an exhaust pipe are
you doing a show tonight no I haven't
had a show for a while I really peaked
with those shows we did in the Arizona
weeks ago yeah isn't that terrible
I've done stand-up a few times but lost
the fire I may be the the booking
getting booked fire I lost that but when
I have had shows I'm still having a lot
of fun doing it yeah I enjoy it quite a
bit more than I did ever before and my
comedy
enjoying it now more than ever what's
the next called oh man I don't know
Conan maybe again that's the only what
Ella you know I'm being realistic
oh thanks I should watch it No thank you
for mourning that I've got yeah thank
you for feeling that you should watch it
no oh well no thanks man mm-hm
no I it went well I think I was relaxed
to use the micro not like oh yeah I
would never I don't know how to just
stick you late what would I do with my
hands did you use no Mike I've done it
both ways
do you like it with a Mike right I do by
sometimes yeah yeah I mean it
or something I mean just I thought I
just the fact that you thought that was
grounds to drop the C bomb I meant that
in the British ah my coat
yeah oh you're a sneaky little polvo
aren't you oh no she she just
nonchalantly Oh on the drive here hell
yeah I'll show you a Gary Busey's house
you know I haven't and I think it's cuz
I'm not looking right but but every once
in a while like one day I was on
high-alert because I saw I jogged I was
at a time I was jogging yeah
I jogged past Josh Brolin and because
he's short is he and yeah I thought he'd
be a bigger guy left AMA he was just I
thought he was this guy that did these
shows at the Palms he's this play
playboy radio guy yeah like hey how you
been like a really important accountant
he says I thought he was caught in a
camp
yeah it's like yeah you look good he's
are yeah yeah
do I know you and I was like oh you're a
famous actor aren't you I'm sorry and I
just ran what's so embarrassing and then
right after that I saw pink and I'm like
I think I'm just on Celebrity high alert
at the on right by the bars at the end
by the cow's end Josh Brolin was walking
he was jogging on the sand like me we
drug past each other I actually stopped
and said hey how you been
it put off the guy whose job I'm like oh
[ __ ] you're James Brolin's kid and then
I ran away I was pretty embarrassed his
daughter worked at a comedy club in New
York she's very sweet really yeah
wow that's amazing - very chill down
earth like you'd never know Wow yeah
that is surprising yeah well he seems to
be chillin down to earth and he had a
moviestar [ __ ] well out of its movie
stars but he's in pee-wee's big
adventure and then I saw later that day
saw the guy that played Kramer when they
redid Seinfeld within the show Seinfeld
that guy he was in Breaking Bad also
it's like the magnet guy he's just a
it's no he's a he's a character actor
that you seen a lot of things but it's
funny to see him during the day he was
like yelling at some you just cuz you're
riding a bike doesn't mean that you he's
yelling at a guy yeah uh-huh another
time I saw Daniel Stern digging through
the garbage angry and swearing what
happened to Daniel Stern I don't know he
looked he had like leaves in his hair
and he was angry and he was like tearing
through the garbage like it skidded
thrown away his retainer or something
he's a good actor - I turned my right
out - well okay thanks yeah I've always
liked them I there is very possible
I think diner my favorite movie with him
in it is breaking away all the cutters
yeah it's good it's Dennis Quaid and him
and it's loosely about cycling and
there's a kid at that dude in there
who's really good who I haven't seen
oh yeah who disappeared and then he came
back like three Dame's well he
disappeared and then and then he came
back and he was like in The Watchmen and
he played this scary
acting's ruff man you could really just
what happened yeah and and they don't
know what happened either like there's
no rhyme or reason he's wonder like is
it like someone disappears as a drug
thing is it I got a job is that I bet
was it the work dried up thing I bet
it's all those things I bet I would I
could relate most with the second one
and just realizing that Oh things aren't
as good as they were a couple years ago
maybe I'll just go ahead and start with
this Web Design thing that I also do
yeah like I would do that that's
probably why I never
you've always oh it's so funny to hear
successful people to think that they
aren't my dad was on an airplane and
heard Paul Newman complaining about his
career thirteen days like a some
out-of-work actor behind me innate looks
and it's Paul Newman
so your dad was sitting ahead
my dad was in first class Paul Newman
was in coach
where was this he'd watched my dad to
eat his free meal where was this oh
there's details I'm sure maybe it was
Robert Redford I don't know maybe it's a
story someone told him but it happened
it happened
I flew South West here from New Orleans
and I actually was like I looked up on
the plane I looked up celebrities flying
Southwest
as a pathetic that I did that but that
there was a hole I'm just looking at
that we're good that as a whole like
several legs
why does the Lebanese love the Southwest
Brad Pitt like what kind of guest Brad
Pitt's not like a regular on Southwest
yeah you just use I wonder if like a guy
like that takes it just as he knows it
again this is nice round here where's
this yeah this is beautiful this you
there's better people than me that
remember words this is a mid Highland
Park maybe I don't know man's must be
slab central something like behind that
gate that's gotta be famous first you
know what I think that people I'll never
know why these people can afford these
houses that guy might be a lawyer I
business owners there is and and and
then you find out where celebrity famous
actor people live and they aren't as
nice as these players like that I don't
know in that and they have modest cars
in front of them sometimes yeah but that
would be such a great wrestling house
yeah it's a big-ass brick house it's
beautiful I mean that's like a big house
but probably if you went inside to be
like holy [ __ ] this is a huge house yeah
but it's not like a man
no no that's just a rich person's house
some rich big [ __ ] house look at this
[ __ ] house I like this one they're
they're light shows on so I like to
glance and see what they're doing inside
Bob Barker it's that kind of 70s boy you
know as a nice house is hell Madrigal
really yeah he had a party in it it's
like what the hell why do you have this
beautiful yeah 70 yeah there's like a
river that goes under it and it's good
about very modern I write when I went in
there it's like haul away oh that's this
is expensive you shouldn't have gotten
this like what do I know we might you
know Jack McBrayer no I don't know him
but you know he is alright
no should I jesseman Bruce on 30 rock oh
oh sure sure I thought you meant but he
has this gorgeous house to stay there
when you're underdone like he would Nev
he wouldn't even joke about me staying
on that well I mean he was joking
well not joking yes yes yeah I can't
just it's like that this isn't as funny
as it is hurting my feelings this line
of joke TIG has a beautiful house now
I'm gonna be in trouble I should have
gone to me we should go to her wedding
yeah you should she's always gonna
remember that I didn't go I mean what
kind of money we talk about what these
gigs people don't know we're talking
about well I'm there I I have a gig the
same day as a wedding and it's my
friend's wedding and I but I tell I said
you're calling her my friend after
revealing her name she she I it might be
loosely I said was out of the weather
five seconds ago I told her I have a gig
and it's kind of money and she said she
said oh my god please don't worry about
it
you got him well I know that and I know
how it is with weddings you work hard to
get there you you buy a flight you're in
a car you get yourself a hotel and I'd
have to do all three of those things to
go
yeah and I unfortunately have a
lifestyle where I can't it's hard for me
to do that but I uh I didn't even get
100 tag and I are much closer than you
probably yeah we lived together seven
years we almost recognized by the state
plus we had a cat together come on I
don't know if yeah yeah we are we were I
call her my ex but uh I she knows that
there's a chance that this happens at
weddings where you go there's and then
you don't even talk to your friend
that's getting married you're
overwhelmed yeah you tell you you talk
to him I thought you just started
yelling but you're yawning they're
overwhelmed yeah so but I do yeah deep
down oh my god making a mistake I can I
can cancel the main are we talking a lot
no no it's also shows that I mean it's
my it it makes this month happen for me
yeah yeah I know I feel you're judging
me thinking I'm not saying no I don't
mean that
yeah it's I would have my price oh you
get excited to go there and then it
sucks
what is hamburgers yeah
boy stur is also come on oh I get it
your food is you want to go right off
the Santa Monica okay cool
what is the what is oyster P well that's
the funny thing as you yeah and it's
hamburgers no arcs actually a ham but it
should be for it because it's called a
ham burger has anyone ever explained
that to us but was it solved was there a
reason ever given just coincidence you
think that and but then you grew up and
I realized well I think that that place
being called the oyster and need I
remind you you asked about this I did
place the oyster is playing paying on
it's calling back to ham burger Oh
it's a couple of get to go a couple of
stats it really doesn't have a payoff I
don't know what do you what is your show
oh I thought you had a show
oh and a couple nights you have a show
right well I'm gonna take care of a cat
for a little bit did you ever say you're
not weekend yeah I have been I didn't do
anything last night or the night before
well I live by the beach and it's hard I
also haven't been very social lately I'm
not look I wasn't invited to anything I
didn't every shows I stayed at home I
didn't feel good about it I felt like a
loser so you were born I was bored and
lonely I wished I had a cat this weekend
on scratch you're gonna name it scratch
oh okay yeah yeah yeah I did and then
they do that repetitive dance so you are
we driving towards the restaurant we are
driving to where you're staying and it's
almost walkable these places but we'll
drop off your bags and then we'll go eat
at the do it though I think it'd be
easier to go straight there oh because
then it's gonna be awkward
oh I got my bag see yeah yeah yeah
you're right
I'm starving I don't have time to talk
or say thank you okay
good point don't worry no one does
that's a that's a Conan O'Brien joke
that he tells every episode what's that
don't worry no one's watching this I
double over people are watching it it's
doing what should be my goal it's not
@midnight anymore that they aren't gonna
have me so I will do Conan I will do how
about that Letterman guy I don't know
why didn't I do Letterman I could have
done that Montana route hits like
Montana people and
why haven't you known him I don't know
I've tried to figure it out
don't think of it I think that that show
very much is relationships with
management managers and heritage like
they do somebody able to be just easy
there has been 900 that is that it's not
like I would be worried about booking
you on this I it's not even that they're
having like actors and writers on I
think it's just like a it's a way to
promote something all of a threesome on
there that's like this is the actor and
two writers from this show I've noticed
they haven't had a lot of stand-ups on
yeah and then they ran out of them
except for me I feel like it is like
it's yeah it's too shady to not be a
stripper it's called gold diggers is it
rich men that get naked and women go
there and watch what it's staring
oh now that the name suggests that gold
digger I guess oh you go in there and
give I don't strip club that's a
horrible name for a strip club though
these are they're a bunch of gold
diggers you throw your money at them and
they get naked
oh you want some blow
just old Hollywood guys with gold rings
oh god we're gonna see Edward James
almost oh you know I just saw here
that's a oh really
still the mustache yeah I was he someone
what do you do it it was he's someone
that I didn't like that's a kid I
remember he got his nose broken and I
was okay that became sensationalist but
he also like way back
oh yeah that's what broke in that he
sort of got
tabloid remember how he was acting like
wouldn't he'd like just jump into the
gunfire during the Gulf War and stuff
yeah I think he was doing stuff and he's
willing he was like picking fights with
Nazis on the show I'll go right now now
he goes to the airport by himself
Wow I could have even I would have made
that really I the reason I didn't go is
I thought maybe what you even knew
wouldn't had a respect yeah yeah well
you're on the right side any
cross-traffic would have murdered you it
saved your life just now
oh that you're honking really he just
wants me to at least try look at this
guy you want to turn around
Vin Diesel Todd Barry in TESOL around
Maya I don't know it looks just like I
mean he looks intense uh hotter court
no oh no that's a beam that's a that's
an Acura he's coming up on your right
let's make sure this isn't Vin Diesel it
really does look like him that would be
it's cuz we were talking about oh man
yeah it's too short and squishy
it's that wasn't dancing looks more like
me that was Vincent de sel he's an
accountant
but yeah he was I need to commute to
work I think we got it I think this the
plan was Western in to Los Feliz
Boulevard yeah take that we'll take that
directly to this restaurant I know that
we will close out the podcast right when
we pull in I already have two calzones
waiting for us is it I know I just
that's what my one of my go-to food
things like I probably had one in my
whole life
no yes
mailing a heart condition special door
yeah I even I've probably had a handful
of them also
well one calzone is a handful but I yeah
they're like the worst thing you can
agree to put in your body how do I make
this pizza a little in New Orleans worse
chicken finger restaurant okay I gotta
go
how was your had you been there and yeah
but there few times was is there like
music jazz yes it getting eroded or no
yeah and is the audience conservative I
would go not at all okay yeah that
sounds great
is there comes a Comedy Festival all yes
fest go ahead and plug them for you are
you cold or warm
I'm just suggested for some reason oh
it's not your car's fault I I didn't
have when I haven't been Austin everyone
had something called cedar fever that
it's allergies but it was so you'd look
out into the air there and it's just
like a claret and commercial there's
just like cotton balls and pieces of
flour flying and so it was obvious all
these people were having allergy I never
had allergies until I moved to Los
Angeles and live by the beach you would
think that's the cleanest air I crime
literally allergic to the ocean air like
you're allergic to
I think that or whale dander I maybe
that's it I don't know I think as you
get older you just get allergies I just
got my brakes redone can you hear that
oh that person's upset him I'm actually
laughing pretty hard
well that was a cartoon character you
know that wasn't just like a that person
was cartoonish and cartoons make me
laugh well how many shows did you do at
this thing
wasn't just one big car I just did one
show oh that's great that's great one
day I'm gonna make demands
what would you rather be doing what
would be your plan B if you weren't
doing standing I have one yeah
illustrations oh yeah what would you do
you'd be good at it you're not a civil
rights attorney
yeah well not as much a civil rights
attorney I think you there'd be a lot of
like a lot of gun freshmen benching
issues and then you lose a case and I
don't know what a civil rights attorney
does I'll go ahead and say that right
now I assume they stand up for the
rights of people who work in civics
civil engineers now that sends that
we're yeah we're doing it I know exactly
where I'm going
isn't that great I am I thank you for
recording with me - I don't know we
might use it really - you know I'll use
it I just might go in and let's try sit
up
trim it do you travel i I've been
meaning to because I think it makes for
a better and we've done it long enough
Wanda where I could cut out some walls
yeah like right now I'll probably cut
this out well I didn't matter no man
that's that's the reason I cut it out
I'm uh I'm just learning we had a girl
helping us for a while and she was out
but we couldn't pay her and then she
started getting busy so I'm like I'll do
it and man I've made nothing but
mistakes recording what you paid her for
what I'm sorry what we didn't we didn't
pair we aren't no one's paying us we did
do a couple sponsor commercials all the
sheets right yeah the sheets are well
yeah they're nice they're really nice
sheets well you can go to parachute
dot-com for $25 off and use the the
promotional code ride it brings you
right to a page with our podcast that's
pretty cool yeah I did through a land
bill Birds okay you're on there yeah all
things are they charming a talent they
there's a couple guy yeah that's there
it's their partnership and you know they
got a couple guys more actively running
it but
yeah it's their podcast network and
they've been getting like bulk like a
someone else sponsor a few of them and
then I guess they just write a check and
they divvy it up I've made a money yet
but I'm gonna sneeze because that's what
we're allergic I'm near the ocean what's
that oh man well that was one of those
sneezes where it was just dry yeah yeah
no I went right on my hand and look
totally dry
look at it yeah yeah I will
oh thank you oh I don't know why because
it was in a plastic envelope I thought
these would be little baby wipes
I noticed cuz I use baby wipes has an
adult and I'm not gonna go into the
detail of wise but you know what I
they're all they all say do not flush
what the hell my think of a cotton
towels you can flush really okay good
yeah I've been flushing I'm willing Lily
I did read an article or saw it art so I
can't say I read it how that how those
hid those wipes you're using you're
clogging are screwing up your settings
okay I won't bother
I'm hungry it's gonna be great food you
think we're gonna like getting every
minute any minute of it any singular
minute of eating we're gonna love that
one moment see look at that house what
does that person do in bomb bodies good
evening
look there's like a cat what do you call
that a round part castle Parliament it's
a beautiful house it's probably
apartments I could probably live there
for just $28,988 let's do a huge ending
you've been listening to do you need a
ride my guest has been Todd Barry Todd
thanks for being on you got it
Thanks you can see Todd in a couple days
at in LA at the don't I know at the echo
Roberts show it's a crowd work show we
go to Oakland Sacramento Reno beautiful
very calm
Todd Barry got calm is where you can go
to see all those dates Oakland sac town
the Bay Area and back down huh well
you've been listening to do you need a
ride I'm gonna honk Dyn AR that's cuz
that's how I yeah that guy's angry
that's angry that's angry that's angry